guten tag
my name is Tom I'm come from Turkey
Istanbul and today I came to travel to
see the Baltic Sea and discover this
beautiful city and let's go and see
the buildings are really nice the
architecture is really different and so
beautiful houses are here you're here
now and the playing card factory in
chasms and we will print a postcard okay
so you'll design your own postcard yes
I'm so excited
1 2 3
oh this is my postcard I can sent a star
move
now I want to go to the church and I
want to see the Baltic Sea and over the
city 363 365 365 366 oh I'm here
it's
I want to take a picture there's a nice
city
it's like home because I I see the sea
and Baltic Sea and the weather is like
and the weather is seems the worst worse
weather and I'm so happy
also the the town is so sweet small and
I really happy I'm really happy to be
here feeling like home
I ordered a fish from Baltic Sea it's
potato its name kinds of hair and I
really want her mouth to taste it
it's delicious
this is the Museum of Baltic fishes and
there are many fishes gluing in Baltic
Sea and now I want to see them and I'm
very excited
the water is more cold than from Turkey
turkey see because of that then there
are differences between the fishes and I
learned that all the fishes are eatable
you
thousand it's very beautiful city and
and now I'm dreaming in the Baltic Sea
and I was like a knife knife and
everything was perfect
you